the vast majority of people who turn out
this way come from a broken kind of
environment at home you can we cannot
want to convict the parents but we want
so badly not to convict them that we
actually end up doing the children a
disservice because we will blame them
before we'll blame the
parents hey folks welcome to the
Darkhorse podcast I have the distinct
pleasure of sitting this afternoon with
Josh slokum who is co-host of the
disaffected podcast
welcome to Darkhorse Josh thanks Brett
appreciate having me yeah it's it's good
to see you um you and I have had a
number of conversations uh outside of
podcast space um but in any case I'm
looking forward to this one I will
confess upfront that events in the last
two days in Israel have uh captured my
attention and have me a little bit
distracted so I'm having to return
myself to the mindset that will put this
conversation in proper context I
apologize for that but it's unavoidable
it is
unavoidable um so let's talk about who
you are before we get to the topic in
question um I have struggled to describe
the disaffected podcast I think probably
you will do a better job than I would
how would you encapsulate the subject
matter of
disaffected sure um disaffected is a
weekly show we have a thesis um my uh my
friend and producer Kevin is the other
half of the show and the thesis is that
we are living in a society where the
kinds of abusive psych um abusive
psychology and abusive actions that we
are familiar with in terms of domestic
abuse and child abuse that those
dynamics that we think of as happening
behind closed doors in the home have now
exploded out of the home basically I
like to say say clust um domestic abuse
has gone public and
feral so the kinds of cognitive
distortions um emotional abuse lying uh
reversing the truth making um
perpetrators out of victims these are
things that are familiar to me from my
childhood growing up in a home uh that
featured this kind of behavior and I now
believe that our mainstream Society not
just the Fringe not just the worst
actors and no not just Twitter but our
mainstream Society itself is acting like
it has a cluster B personality
disorder um that's that's so we we we
say the show is politics culture and
relationships through a psychological
lens and the lens that we use is
particularly focused on this cluster of
Personality Disorder
traits excellent all right um now let's
talk about your background
as it is relevant am I correct that you
are you are not a degreed psychologist
you are correct I am not a mental health
professional I do not have a psychology
degree I do not represent to anyone that
I am a mental health professional what I
am is a very well- read Layman and a
Layman who has extensive personal
lifelong experience with this psychology
in my home and who also has worked
around people um with these traits and
disorders and and now I actually uh
consult with clients who are facing
these difficulties in their personal and
professional lives so um I'm I don't
like the term I don't like the
connotations that it has but you know if
if you'll Brack it all that off and just
uh give me a dispensation I'm a child
abuse
Survivor right um and what I want to do
is help people to understand because I
think that this does help people
understand why we are living in the
world we are living in and what woke
actually
is
excellent um I will say the name of this
podcast is obviously Darkhorse and the
intent when I started it was to talk to
people who you wouldn't ordinarily
imagine would have a great deal of
expertise in an area but had shown great
promise through their behavior rather
than uh advanced degrees and formal
accolades so anyway you are a dark horse
in the exact sense that I meant this uh
when I named the
podcast um in other words frankly the
expert class has so embarrassed itself
in the last several years that I think
all of us should be looking for anybody
whose uh Insight in the world is
actually predictive of things and we
should be ignoring things like formal
degrees that often uh disguise pure
foolishness
so um I I welcome your amateur status
thank you our first sponsor for this
episode is Paleo Valley paleo Valley
makes a huge range of products from
supplements like fish row and organ
complex grass-fed beef bone broth and
superfood bars everything we've tried
from them has been terrific including
their golden milk made with tons of
turmeric but we're going to talk today
about beef
sticks the beef in these delicious
snacks comes from small American-owned
Farms that practi practice rotational
grazing paleo Valley's beef sticks are
100% grass-fed and finished entirely
organic and naturally fermented 100%
grass-fed beef is more nutritious than
grain-fed beef in many ways including
that it contains more calcium magnesium
potassium zinc phosphorus beta carotene
and iron it's also
delicious if you're thinking that paleo
Valley's beef sticks are like slim gems
you're wrong for one thing unlike slim
gims paleo Valley beef sticks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts
for another paleo Valley's beef sticks
are actually good for you ingredients
hiding in most beef sticks and jerky
include MSG hormones hydrogenated oils
and brominated vegetable oil which if
you're wondering what that is was first
patented as a flame retardant and now
it's on a lot of food but not if you buy
paleo Valley furthermore unlike other
meat snacks paleo Valley uses natural
fermentation to preserve its beef sticks
this gives the beef sticks a long shelf
life without the use of harmful acids
and chemicals and with the added benefit
of contributing to a healthy gut paleo
valy beef sticks are also ketofriendly
and make a great protein reach snack to
grab when you're on the go like running
out the door for a meeting podcast or
going on a bike ride paleo Valley
doesn't cut Corners they Source only the
highest quality ingredients and are
passionate about human health but also
environmental restoration and animal
welfare and they are familyowned company
try paleo Valley's beef sticks today
you'll be glad you did head over to
paleo val.com
Darkhorse for 15% off your first
order our second sponsor for this
episode is mind Bloom mind Bloom is the
leader in atome ketamine therapy
offering a combination of scientifically
robust medicine with clinically guided
support for people looking to improve
their mental health and well-being if
you or someone you love is struggling
with mental health issues those issues
May Loom large in your life there is no
one-size fits-all solution but you know
that you or your loved ones need
something that will help achieve a real
and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's time
for you to consider a guided ketamine
Therapy Program for mind Bloom mind
Bloom could be your next and most
successful chapter in improving your
mental health and well-being mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower cost
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience to begin take mind
Bloom's online assessment and schedule a
video consult with a licensed clinician
to determine if mind Bloom is right for
you if approved you'll discuss your
health history and goals for mental
health treatment with your clinician to
tailor your mind Bloom regimen mind
Bloom will send you a kit in the mail
complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only four
sessions 89% of Mind Bloom clients
reported improvements in their symptoms
of depression and anxiety reports one
client on their site quote mind Bloom
has enabled me to release the whole of
negative thought patterns in my
life mind Bloom has has guided so many
people into a better chapter of mental
health and well-being right now mind
Bloom is offering our listeners $100 off
your first six session program when you
sign up at mind bloom.com
Darkhorse and use the code Darkhorse at
checkout go to mind bloom.com Darkhorse
promo code Darkhorse for $100 off your
first six session program today that's m
n d
bom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse so let's
figure out how to Broach this subject
and let us also say that this is an
interesting moment to be talking about
the possibility that cluster b um
pathologies have broken into a larger
scale and maybe dominating something in
our political and sociocultural
Landscape because of course that idea
has now emerged uh under some other
names I have seen Michael shellenberger
talk about this and I believe Michael
shellenberger references your work in
his presentation is that correct yeah
yeah he um yeah uh he rounded up uh
three or four people uh in his piece
last week that um that he says uh have
been helpful to his formulating his
thinking on that yeah so uh that's good
I believe he has learned a lot from you
and uh that it shows I've also seen
Chris rufo has recently recently I think
published a book uh on the topic of
cluster B diagnoses and their relevance
to things like the woke are you sure
that he published a book or or um is it
perhaps more um he may have published a
book I wasn't aware of that but I do
know that he released um a long article
uh and also um an 11 minute video so
yeah it has been uh coming out there if
there's a book I was unaware until you
just told me interesting um I am not
sure if my memory is faulty here but I
thought that the article had been a uh
an excerpt from a book but maybe I have
imagined that in any case he has
certainly talked uh very publicly about
the possibility that cluster B um
disorders have scaled up into larger
social
phenomena as far as you know does he
site your work no he does not he does
not site your work all right I find that
interesting in
um it's hard to imagine that he has been
thinking deeply about this topic and is
not aware of your ongoing exploration of
it but who knows what we don't know um
in any case I think it would be
interesting since you're both uh deeply
involved in this question it would be
interesting to uh hear you pull your
thoughts and see whether or not there
might not be some uh
emergent uh set of understandings that
would be produced by uh the sum of those
parts
so uh let us hear your
encapsulation of your thesis regarding
cluster B personality disorders and the
larger social environment okay so I I
don't know your audience's level of
familiarity with the topic but um I
would assume that uh there are plenty
out there for whom this will be new
terminology yeah so let's just start
with what is cluster B good okay so I
like to start actually with what are
personality disorders think that's
that's a foundational concept i' I think
people need to be able to grasp to um to
think uh carefully about this
personality
disorders are a kind you you can think
of them as a kind of mental illness
but they are not the kind of mental
illness that that phrase mental illness
probably evokes in people who are
listening right now mainly generally
I'll say this before I go I go a lot
further too um because this is bound to
come up among your audience perhaps in
the
response I'm going to be speaking I'm
going to be making a lot of
generalizations I'm going to be speaking
broadly I am a reductionist by Nature I
I understand the necessity for comp
apption and Nuance but it is my belief
that right now in the era that we live
in we actually need a good old-fashioned
dose of pattern detection and
reductionism to common denominators so I
am going to be making some very broad
General statements I believe that they
are largely accurate I'm not going to
caveat everything I say I'm not going to
give a series of not alls and not in
this case I will not do that so I always
and I ask my own audience Supply your
own not alls I am aware that what I say
will not be applicable to every single
situation I am also aware that my thesis
is not the only thesis that can help
explain this so now that I've gotten
that out of the way um tedious as it
sounds you're probably going to
appreciate it Brett because one of the
things that comes back very quickly from
people who don't want to hear this is oh
you're painting with a broad brush this
is you know you're projecting one man's
personal rare experience uh onto a whole
thing you know it's it's very very
common reaction well let me let me uh uh
intrude here to say that one of the
things that I think we face when we look
at psychological phenomena is that
psychology aspires to be a science in
the way that uh that biology or physics
or chemistry is a science and it has a
problem which is that not only is it a
complex system which it shares with
Biology more generally but it is a
complex system
built of information and information
processors in the mind these are things
we understand very poorly and so what
psychology is left with is the
recognition of patterns of phenomena
that is not the same thing as
comprehending the underlying mechanisms
and so we have to treat psychology very
differently than we treat uh other
disciplines because instead of being
able to point for example to an enzyme
that accomplishes a particular reduction
and activation energy for a particular
set of reactants what we have instead
are checklists where oftentimes we'll
say this disorder is present if nine of
the following 12 conditions are there
that is not a precise landscape we may
be talking about multiple phenomena
which are combined in one basket and so
in any case your need to generalize is
clear your need to imply caveats for
everything should be assumed anybody who
is speaking carefully and rigorously in
this landscape is either going to be so
um dogged by the requirement to say not
all and all else being equal in front of
every sentence yeah or it just has to be
assumed so anyway I know why you're
there I will say one slight bit of push
back on the issue of
reductionism reductionism
is
one fantastic side of a two-sided coin y
the other side is synthesis synthesis is
my uh stock and trade and so in any case
I do believe that the requirement for
proper reductionism is present but the
need to then build those reductive
elements into a synthetic hole that
makes some kind of sense is equally
important agreed and I believe that you
do that as well so I don't want I don't
want you to Corner yourself as a
reductionist when in fact I think you're
involved in both of these processes
thank you uh that's not a perspective I
get very often usually it one one does
feel defensive uh when when talking
about this uh it's unpopular um so
personality disorders so if we think of
them as a kind of mental illness they're
not the kind of mental illness that your
audience uh just thought of when I used
that that phrase what most people think
of are things like depression even
chronic major
depression uh chronic pathological
levels of anxiety that we might describe
as generalized anxiety disorder or panic
disorder uh it's not schizophrenia where
a person is actually out of touch with
reality we're not talking about that
that's not the people I'm talking about
um so they're not classic mental
illnesses and again I ask people to to
to to understand that this is this is
general and there are overlaps and there
are cases where things can look like
other things
but we tend to think of personality
disorders are what they say they are
they are disorders of
Personality yes it is
personal yes it is talking about the who
the you who you are it's very personal
this is why it's hard for people
sometimes to accept hearing it because I
can't say oh no this isn't a personal
criticism it is this is this is about
who you are as a person and what I mean
by that is they are
longstanding deeply deeply ingrained
patterns of
mentation emotional processing and
behavior to yourself and to other people
deeply ingrained
pathological States now now hold on hold
on I I have to I now see what my role is
GNA be here um I'm going to have to
translate this into evolutionary terms
and you should just know I have a a
principle that I live by which is that
all true narratives must reconcile which
is to say if you're if you're saying
true things about psychology and I
understand things in terms of
evolutionary biology then we must be
able to translate between them and if we
can't it's because we don't know
something yet or we've got something
wrong so when you say these are you use
the term pathological right yes when you
say that these are pathological
disorders do you mean to imply that the
person exhibiting them necessarily comes
out behind as a result of the presence
of these disorders the way Define behind
if I if I say um that um
influenza is a pathogen I am implying
that to have influenza does not give you
an advantage that it costs you
inherently the amount it costs you may
vary but that it cost you is uh inherent
okay is it true that these disorders
inherently disadvantage the people who
have
them that's very broad but I'm going to
take it in a particular direction that I
think you're aiming
for
um what I am saying when I say
pathological in this context what I mean
is that they are negative and
deleterious behaviors negative to whom
well negative to other people one my
orientation to this I'm going to um I'm
going to disclose my priors to everybody
I'm going to tell you what all my biases
are and all my prior assumptions okay my
bias is to those who are affected and
harmed by this I do not have warm and
sympathetic feelings to those with
cluster B personality disorders I will
not pretend that I do um I am concerned
because I believe we're living in a
society right now where destructive and
hateful kinds of behaviors and emotional
manipulations are considered normal and
the people against whom they are
directed are are um are not listened to
We tend to think like for example we say
um well somebody suffers from
narcissistic personality disorder it's
built into the very way we talk about
this my response to that would be yeah
do you know who suffers from
narcissistic personality disorder
his wife their children right I'm not
concerned here primarily I do not have a
therapeutic interest personally myself
in most of the people who I believe have
these disorders I'm on the side of their
victims and I don't want to egg that to
I realize that that is also an
emotionally charged term um so wait hold
hold on I think we've just got something
really important here okay this was a a
a paradox I've wondered about coming
into this conversation I now think I
know the answer to it
these are pathologies inherently but in
order to understand that they are
pathologies in the same sense that
influenza is a pathology y we have to
understand that the correct unit to be
looking to be evaluating the consequence
over is not the individual correct that
the individual May well come out ahead
but the extent that their slice of pie
grows as a result of their pathology at
a cost to the entire size of the P that
they are draining those around them in
order to embolden or enrich themselves
that that is the nature of the pathology
you see it clearly is pathological if
you look at you know the family or the
lineage or whatever it is that has had
its wealth burned up by this pattern yes
so you will end up like when you're
saying does this give you an advantage I
mean I don't know the answer to this but
I play these I play these I turn these
models over in my mind constantly I'm
always thinking about this I I have
questions for example about um Can
psychopathy which is and we'll get to
that I'm going to actually give people
I'm going to give them a quick overview
of the cluster B disorders but you C you
know I can imagine a plausible World in
which you might find if you looked at
the data that having a psychopathic
orientation to the world in certain
contexts gave you a reproductive fitness
advantage not necessarily constantly
over all Millennia and all time but
certainly perhaps within certain
contexts and historic IAL epics that
that's that's a bigger question we can't
answer that whole question here um but
no it's not the case that it's not the
case that everybody with these disorders
ends up losing out and never has any
power they often not all of them some of
them do but very often they rise to
positions of extraordinary power above
the average person and they become
wealthy and successful and they go
undetected so it is sometimes an
advantage to the individual yeah and we
have a bias yeah our understanding of
this even a bias that I know extends
into the psychological literature on the
topic because we tend to discover the
sociopathy or psychopathy of those who
aren't especially great at it yes the
ones who get caught yes and the ones who
succeed brilliantly and manage to evade
detection may not read as sociopaths and
therefore when we study sociopaths we go
and look at the cases of basically
failed sociopaths and it's it's too easy
to conclude oh these are badly wired
people rather than these are people
wired selfishly who drain those around
them and that's why they did well yes
correct so what are the cluster B
personality disorders and what does the
term cluster bam mean this is an
American diagnostic schema from the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders um uh there are there
are three clusters of personality
disorders and again personality
disorders are not just a passing Cloud
it's not depression that affects your
friend some days but then when she comes
out of it there's a a normal normal
range temperament person underneath
there right that's how it's not like
that this this is who the person is all
the time across domains not necessarily
exactly the same but this is a pervasive
pattern this is a higher level okay this
is a higher level stuff we're dealing
with here um more
dangerous less treatable often most
often often not very treatable at all so
what are they there's clusters a b and c
I'm concerned only with cluster B this
cluster is called the dramatic and
erratic personality disorders it
includes ostensibly
four and I say ostensibly I'll come back
to why I say that they are borderline
personality disorder that does not mean
somebody who's only on the border and
isn't really there it's a full
personality disorder it is severe by
definition my understanding is that the
term borderline refers to the fact that
the condition is between two other
conditions not that it is borderline
pathological correct um it it it refers
to people who straddle the line between
neurosis and
psychosis Neurosis is negative
emotionality rumination depression
Obsession anxiety all humans have a
level of neurosis all of us right normal
range people and personality disordered
people Psych psychosis it's base term it
doesn't mean violent killer people
that's the colloquial misunderstanding
psychosis means you are actually
disconnected from reality and it doesn't
necessarily mean that you are hearing
voices although that is one form of
psychosis it could mean that you have an
incredibly elaborate baroke fantasy of
persecution that people might think of
in terms of paranoid traits um the
borderline tends to hover on the cusp of
this unstably what I don't remember the
the the uh clinician and writer who
coined this phrase but it's brilliant
you can think of borderlines as stably
unstable um so the core of borderline is
fears of Abandonment having a a weak or
absent sense of self um emotional
clinginess severe and rapid mood swings
and I don't mean I'm cranky in one
minute and then I'm more pleasant the
next I mean swings from suicidal or
homicidal rage and despair to
Elation and I love you more than anyone
else in the world within the span of
hours or one day it is not bipolar
people mistake this all the time not
bipolar not manic depression manic
depressives bipolars tend to cycle over
weeks and the curve looks like this the
borderline looks like this okay so if
it's minutes hours or days you don't
have a bipolar friend you probably have
a borderline friend so for those of you
for those of the audience who are only
listening and not watching what You'
just done with your hands is you've said
that a a manic depressive uh a Bipolar
person I hope I'm using those terms
correctly as synonyms um has a like an S
curve pattern over the course of weeks
they may be uh
debilitated uh one week and 3 weeks
later they may be elated and highly
productive with the borderline you've
got these very Jagged sharp Peaks that
over the span of hours causes the person
to go from one phase into the other
correct so that's borderline personality
disorder narcissistic personality
disorder is the other one um that seems
self-explanatory and to a large degree
it is um but two things I want to point
out about narcissistic uh personality
one all cluster bees not only NPD
narcissistic PD all four of them all
have extraordinarily elevated levels of
narcissism that is a commonality that
binds the cluster bees together okay
self-obsession self-obsession yes you
can call it solipsism you can call it
extreme self-centeredness you can call
it actually narcissism but all of them
are characterized by this narcissistic
PD there are two main
types it's easy to see the class classic
grandiose narcissist the brager the
Donald Trump right I have the best cars
the most beautiful women the most voters
the this that and the other thing right
you can see this guy coming we've all
known this guy at some point in our
lives he's obnoxious at the bar uh you
know he's always bragging about his new
sports car you know etc etc that's your
grandiose narcissist but there's another
kind and I think this kind is actually
more active more prevalent and more
dangerous today called the covert
narcissist they don't have the same
affect they don't walk in chest first
and say I'm the biggest jock da d d d da
instead they present falsely as victims
they present themselves as
extraordinarily caring deeply empathetic
and compassionate people much more than
you much more than her I'm the most
compassionate I care more about them and
by constructing a sort of angelic image
of themselves as this deeply empathic
person they man ulate other people and
they extract egotistical Supply from
people by presenting as a victim and
saying things like you know I've worked
for 25 years I've cooked more food for
the homeless than any other person on
the face of the planet and no one has
ever recognized me and I have been
oppressed and d d d you see this in woke
all the time covert narcissism is just
woke through and through and through all
right so I have a question for you and I
do want you to absolutely complete the
the chart you're you're building for us
um but it's been years since I've read
about narcissistic personality disorder
I wasn't I don't think I was aware until
you you have alerted me to it of the
covert version of this which the
relevance to woke is quite clear now
that you say it um
but
the the thing that struck me when I read
into this topic was that the let's take
the brager version of The
Narcissist we
normies for lack of a better term
yes see this person and imagine that
their internal experience of self is
also grand a mirror for the outside and
we misunder understand that in fact they
may be a deeply insecure person and that
what we are seeing on the outside is a
compensation for this correct uh deep
sort of self-doubt correct not Maybe not
maybe are always so does that also apply
to the covert narcissist it applies to
all of the cluster B personality
disorders all four of them in all
subtypes insecurity insecurity that's
right um because and and because we're
going to talk a lot about abuse in this
um child abuse and domestic abuse
um in the vast majority of cases we
can't know the backstories and histories
of everybody we can't even verify them
but in the vast majority of cases
those who end up with cluster be
personality disorders end up that way
because of abusive and neglectful
childhoods genuine trauma usually did
occur to these people that is true they
weren't they didn't just pop out of the
womb this way yes we all have different
levels of hardwired inclinations
vulnerabilities and strengths some of us
are more highly strong than others and
would be regardless of how our childhood
was some of us are more stable this is
true but but when you look at the case
histories of people diagnosed with these
disorders the rate of child abuse child
sexual abuse child emotional abuse
abandonment neglect is
Skyhigh okay yeah I think that is um a
crucial point to understand and this is
um it's
also tragically disruptive of our
ability to have a proper conversation
about this yes so let me just as an
aside say that in many cases of um the
sexual abuse of children the person
engaged in this has a history of being
abused in exactly this way you tell me
if I've got any of this wrong that's
right it's not Universal but it is
there's a strong correlation yes a
strong unignorable correlation correct
that unignorable correlation means that
we have to wrestle with properly dealing
with the horrifying moner who is
destroying a person's life by abusing
them sexually and we have to reconcile
ourselves to the fact that that person
may be there as the result of the fact
that someone did this to them and so
though they are now monster they started
as victim yes and um you know that
requires adult levels of nuance to just
even grapple with it um the Temptation
Of Those Who focus on the victim part of
that story will be to let the monster
off the hook which we mustn't do and we
do constantly
yes all right okay so then quickly just
to end up the the four categories
histrionic personality disorder in my
view is very close to borderline may
even be a subset of borderline I'm I'm
open to this it's an ongoing
conversation I'm having with myself but
it it means what it sounds like and and
let me disambiguate here there's a big
misconception about atmology here honic
does not come from hysterical it the
root word is not hysterical this is not
a misogynist or sexist extrapolation uh
you br you might be shocked how many
people incorrectly believe this the root
is the Greek word hyos which means like
an actor not uterus not
hystero hyos yes I I I would probably be
shocked at how many people had that
misconception uh including me until just
now um so anyway thank you it's a
helpful it's a misconception that
happens to be quite handy for
doctrinaire feminists so um that's where
I see a lot of it um then we have what's
called antisocial personality disorder
and the audience knows this colloquially
as either sociopathy or
psychopathy um
so now I've described the four cluster
wa wait wait hold on uh I've done a lot
of reading in that area too uh I am
perennially troubled by
the uh failure to clearly delineate
between these two some people treat them
as synonyms and some people treat them
as distinct either by degree or by some
characteristic uh can you just tell me
how it is that you're using these two
terms yes I can um I I it will not fully
satisfy you um here's here's the deal
sociopath and psychopath are not
actually recognized Universal clinical
terms they are contest Ed terms I know
people don't like to hear this there
isn't an answer I can't settle it for
you I can tell you antisocial
personality disorder is the
technical recognized clinical term
sociopath and psychopath are used
colloquially um the what I warn people
against and and I I am certain that
right now as you and I are talking or
well no this isn't live but when people
start commenting on this I can I can
write their comment for you I'm going to
do it right now you're going to get
people who say psychopaths are born and
sociopaths are made and you really
should have uh said that and everybody
knows that and blah people get very head
up about this no there is not agreement
or consensus on that I wish that there
were I like Clarity too well let me
um May maybe I should let you finish
your thought here and then I would like
to introduce a hypothesis a partial
hypothesis that I'm thank you I'm going
to finish that and then I'm GNA I have
something that's very important I'm
going to wrap that up okay um so when I
use them I do use them as synonyms I
know that is unsatisfying to some of you
but I'm not doing wrong because there
isn't a right we haven't we don't have
consensus on it okay so I use them as
synonyms um sensibly there are four
cluster B personality disorders I no
longer believe that most humans can be
easily categorized in only one of four
slots I think it is closer to the truth
that there is such a state of mind a
real extent objectively observable state
of mind that we call cluster
B however that's real but most people
not all but
most will have a helping of
traits from each of the four categories
or heavy helping from here a heavy
helping from here I'll give a concrete
example in the real world my mother I
can describe my mother two ways I can
say my mother is cluster B and has uh
traits from this slot this slot this
slot the short hand that I use to
describe my mother which is slightly
inaccurate is that she has both
borderline and narcissistic personality
disorders do I think that my mother has
two discreet um observable Hardline she
just happens to have two things that are
morbit together no I don't believe that
I believe my mother has a cluster be
mind and that she has the heaviest
possible combination of both borderline
and narcissistic traits so yeah I would
this is one of these places that goes
exactly back to what we were discussing
a few minutes ago about psychology you
know more often providing a checklist
and then putting you into a category the
right way to think about this if if
you're accurate in your understanding is
that you have a large category that
contains components and the question is
one of AD mixture yes which which
components in what measure and each of
the combinations will produce a somewhat
unique um outgrowth in terms of behavior
so that there are people there are
people and there are enough of them that
they're noticeable and we can talk about
them there are people who Hue much more
closely to the classic presentation of
borderline personality disorder or the
classic presentation of psychopathy and
there are in fact when you get to the
psychopathic end the truly Machiavellian
conscience free that's the thing that
that distinguishes when you're all the
way at the end that includes antisocial
sociopathy
psychopathy you can say for
example that many I don't know how many
but I do think many people with
borderline personality disorder do have
the capacity for empathy it is
compromised it is unstable and sometimes
they cannot access that empathy when
they need it that's bored when you get
down when you get down to sociopathy and
psychopathy these are people who don't
have any damned empathy it's not that
they can't access it it's that it does
not exist they don't care about you at
all okay so I want to do a little uh
hypothetical uh potential cleanup of
that concept based on what I know and in
this context you are very definitely the
expert and I am uh a rank amateur by
comparison but what has always troubled
me so first of all let me just say on
the distinction between psychopathy and
sociopathy following what I think was
the um description I believe of Robert
hair uh do I have the person right yeah
you do um he once described this as a
distinction between somebody who is
indifferent to your suffering that would
be the sociopath okay versus somebody
who Delights in it that would be the
psychopath and that seems to me a uh
nonarbitrary
distinction it is it is a it is a real
distinction um another word for it what
the most accurate word I believe is
we're talking about the difference
between a stist and a non- sadist yes
this is sadism that we're talking about
right somebody who's willing who feels
none of your pain
as they inflict it doesn't necessarily
seek to inflict it they're just willing
to do whatever whatever puts them ahead
somebody is actually looking to deliver
pain is a very different creat yes and
this it's not only a real distinction
but it is a Salient distinction uh for
personal safety as well absolutely um
your your soop if okay I'll I'll agree
for the sake of this conversation we're
having I'll agree to this definition
okay so I want to add one one more thing
though so actually two things one I
suspect part of why we trip over the
concept of sociopathy and
psychopathy let's take them as a
pair is and the reason that we often see
people who have at least sociopathy rise
to extreme levels of power and influence
is that these things are not
inherently
maladaptive that they actually there's a
way that we could look at the world
where we we would say actually if you
describe the characteristics of a
sociopath that that person would be
perfectly placed on a battlefield
fighting an enemy that must be destroyed
correct you do not want that person
suffering from empathy as they are
destroying an enemy that threatens Your
Existence exactly right so you would
imagine that a society might have a
mechanism for producing a certain number
of sociopaths so that it can be made or
at least accommodating them right so so
my thought is sociopaths would make
sense if they were pointed outwards in a
prior world I don't want to live in that
world I think we have an alternative to
it but in a prior world where lineages
destroyed other lineages having
sociopaths who face outwards and can do
what needs to be done to keep the
population safe makes perfect adaptive
sense it doesn't strike me as
pathological and what we have that is
pathological is that this pattern is now
deployed arbitrarily so that people are
going after their own population with
the same toolkit and that is very
destructive so but then this leads to
this next
question we are
fascinated I think all of us by stories
of people who based on their behavior
would have to be included in this
category Mobsters for example yes right
Mobsters who will um kill for business
reasons they will torture in order to
disincentivize an enemy from doing XY or
but famously are extremely loyal and you
may tell me I've got it wrong but appear
to love their families maybe even to an
extraordinary
degree and the idea of a person who is
sociopathic in one context and familial
in another suggests to me that there's a
facultative piece to this puzzle that
there is such a thing as a person who is
contextually
sociopathic and it may also be that we
and this is a very unpleasant thought to
me but nonetheless I still think it's
accurate if you
consider that there are terrible Horrors
that take place
remotely about which you are essentially
indifferent that we can all detect in
ourselves that there is sort of a zone
of remoteness that makes us def facto
deao
sociopathic relative to the suffering of
people we have little connection
to I I absolutely understand what you're
saying um to the second part I would say
respectfully I think that that drags the
concept out so far that it loses it may
lose actual functional meaning got it I
don't think that can properly be called
sociopathic yeah I don't think it is
sociopathic I think it's normal and the
problem is that it go ahead
I'm also going to challenge you on the
mobster um I'm not saying that I know
that I'm right um I I I suspect that I
am I can be argued into a different
position but I suspect that may be a
romantic falsehood um you have posited
the existence of a kind of person who is
fully sociopathic when it comes to
business but then is a loving family man
at home that guy doesn't exist Brett
that's not real I I am that is one
possibility I have been wondering about
because the stories that we are so
fascinated by are
dramatizations yeah they're Hollywood
right so there's a question about
whether or not we in the audience are
being you know whether these are
effectively
um uh like some kind of genre in which
the possibility of such a Monster who
walks amongst us and behaves normally
with respect to their family is that
much more terrifying than somebody who's
simply broken that that that that may be
um I and again um nothing is 100% And I
will change my mind if evidence comes
along to contradict it but I'm going to
stake a position here I don't believe
that charact character exists I don't
believe that type of human exists I
think it's nonsense um that is largely
Hollywood and largely
um here you think of it this way um I
don't mean to say you're full of
nonsense BR no no no you're you're doing
exactly what you should do and I love
the idea that the way to resolve this
puzzle is to recognize that there's no
evidence of such a person I don't know
if there is evidence but I I don't I
don't believe there is and frankly it
doesn't even it doesn't make
epistemological sense when you walk
through it when you step through it in
your mind it simply it falls apart it
doesn't hang together um we we say for
example um I had a conversation I had a
conversation with my therapist about
something similar a couple years ago um
as you can imagine I we we spent a lot
of time talking about how people's minds
work you know my my family is shot
through with cluster B personality
disorders I'm a typical outcome of such
a family so this is warp and woof of our
of our conversation and I said to him
one day therapist what are we to make of
the claims that we often hear and we
often hear these claims in True Crime uh
which is a genre I like very much I'm
fascin I I am fascinated by dark
psychology absolutely uh admitted um but
we often hear these claims that you know
so so who ended up being a a murderer
grew up in a perfectly normal middle
class home with loving parents and D we
hear this all the bloody time we have no
good reason to take that on faith yet we
do we take it on faith all the time but
we don't have any good reason to take it
on faith because it goes against
everything that we do actually know and
there's a lot we don't but we know an
awful lot about childhood development in
some ways and it simply is not
true that there's
well so I said to my therapist what do
we make of these claims where we've got
we've got a woman who clearly has
borderline personality disorder and
probably secondary Psychopathic states
that she gets into even if she's not a
global psychopath every day 24 hours a
day and and we're CL you know she she
came from a loving household this that
and my therapist said to me two things
number
one are people are self-reports always
reliable do we believe everything that
ever everyone says about their childhood
and we believe that that is the most
accurate rendition of course that it
isn't our self-reports can be unreliable
we also are
fighting I believe that this is a fairy
story that we normal people tell
ourselves so that we don't have to face
the real world we don't want it to be
real that there are wicked and actually
evil parents that is so disturbing to us
and we can see why it's disturbing it is
so activating and disturbing to us that
we will actually tell ourselves a fairy
tale lie to avoid having to deal with it
so we like to think and I when I say we
I mean broad pop culture General Society
we we would rather believe in The Bad
Seed than we than we would than we would
believe in the depravity of the parent I
think that explains a lot of why we have
these romantic Notions about the guy
who's really loving at home but he he'll
he'll cap somebody uh for business I
don't think he's real okay um I want
want to push back just slightly I think
I agree with your instinct here almost
completely that um normal developmental
environments almost never produce severe
psychological pathology correct that
said I believe that there are causes
disruptions that can occur that are not
about a failure of parenting I believe
that as well traumatic brain injury is
one example traumatic brain injury
toxins there are various things that can
disrupt this development which would
leave uh good parents with an offspring
who had been uh wrecked by by one of
these patterns and the other thing is I
believe that
we those of us who derive our moral
sense
from uh
Western values I believe are also likely
to trip over the fact that we know it is
wrong to infer somebody's guilt without
proof right in fact our legal system is
biased to uh release 10 innocent people
uh I mean to release 10 guilty people
rather than convict an single innocent
person so when it is that what we've got
is somebody is
behaving um
destructively it's not uh a a perfectly
solid case that their parenting must
have been broken and so we we we quite
correctly do not want to convict the
parents but that means that we also
ignore the overwhelming pattern which is
that it is a broken pattern of parenting
that generally produces these things yes
the problem you're you're correct the
problem and it really is a problem is
that our our our bias misleads us and it
causes us to be inac accurate it is
simply a fact it's not my opinion it's
not some clinician's opinion it's a fact
that the vast majority of people who
turn out this way come from a broken
kind of environment at home you can we
cannot want to convict the parents but
we want so badly not to convict them
that we actually end up doing the
children a disservice because we will
blame them before we'll blame the
parents I'm seeing this all over the
place Brett I'm sorry it's very
disturbing to me um very disturbing to
me normal range people decent people
people you might describe as good we all
have good and bad in us but I'm not
talking about people who are hateful or
who are abusing their children but we
are so
damned emotionally fragile these days
and so used to lying to ourselves about
who we really are as people our entire
Society is a lie at this point that
we've got these normal range parents I
see this happening every day I I look at
forums online forums for
um for parents of children who identify
as transgender or or children who have
been transitioned either by another
parent in a divorce situation or um uh
uh an intrusive medical system or social
work or something like
that and to a person to a person
almost let me not go too
far I would guess about 80% of the
parents who describe their family
situation and they're certainly in
Strife they're very upset their children
don't speak to them anymore their
children claim to be a sex that they are
not 80% of these people you nothing was
nothing ever went wrong you know we were
great parents we loved our kids we never
did this we never did that many of
course many most of them probably didn't
beat their children abuse is not a
synonym for physical beating abuse and
neglect take a lot of different forms
but what bothers me I expect people to
rationalize to get out from under their
own guilt we all do that but the parents
around them oh it must be so so sad for
you I'm sorry your teenager is treating
you so badly I can't believe and I think
to myself I'm sorry this this does
emotionally activate me as as you can
tell I get furious at this and I'm just
like wake up you are talking about a
17-year-old here you would rather
because you parents you emotionally
identify with other parents
because and you are reading into you are
protecting your own ego by making sure
these other parents can't be seen as
having failed because then you might you
might have to question if you did the
best job this is all understandable but
it has driven us to the point where we
where we react as if it is more
reasonable and more numerically likely
that there's all these bad seed kids
popping up out of nowhere than that
there might be a pattern of Parental
problems does this make sense oh oh it
makes absolute sense and in fact uh one
of
my uh longstanding gripes against
psychology is
that it it obsesses about the individual
when evolutionarily speaking it makes no
sense to do so that in fact especially
in light of what kind of creature humans
are what we have is a system of what
would be called dual inheritance we get
our genes which program us far less than
any other creature that has ever existed
and then we have a package of Behavioral
traits that are passed outside of the
genome almost entirely from parents to
offspring and it is the noise in that
part of the
transmission that causes most of the bad
programming um and so in any case the
the idea that a psychologist you walk
into the psychologist's office and you
say you know doc I'm
miserable the the uh clinical
orientation is to fix that problem
rather than to ask if you're miserable
because you're abusing the people around
you and they rightly hate you for it
right so you know so the point is the
real question is it's very inconvenient
to understand these problems
holistically in the context that they
happen but it's the only rigorous proper
way to do it yes sometimes an individual
may have an individual problem but the
degree to which that is not always the
case is Extreme and um anyway I think uh
I think psychology has done itself a
tremendous disservice by um treating the
clinical practice as synonymous with the
scientific discipline in fact we just
simply do not know enough scientifically
to treat people what what what
psychologists do as a as a service is
something that has traditionally been
done by friends family members members
of the clergy people who are in a
position to see the you know imagine a
clergy person
giving advice to people able to see the
effects on children of parents myopia
that's a very powerful position um from
which to advise in a way that fixes
something that is a system um so in any
case I'll get off my soap box but I do
think psychology is obsessed with the
individual because the individual is
easy to study and describe and that that
misses the point a large fact the time I
think you're right and and you're you're
right fractally because it it goes
deeper and more detailed too psychology
is not only obsessed with the individual
to the exclusion of of the family or
social system in in
which good therapy good psychological
practice takes this into account I know
that that exists because I am now
experiencing it in my five-year
therapeutic relationship but it is
numerically rare these days psychology
has has significantly declined um even
if you didn't think it was very great
before it's much worse now than it used
to be well in large measure because the
same
uh the same forces the same uh hypnotic
obsession with Pharmaceuticals and I
know that psychologists don't prescribe
Pharmaceuticals themselves but the
discipline of treating people for
psychological disorders has so uh
diverted itself on a phony theory of
chemical imbalance to treating people
with uh drugs and if I may say one more
thing as foolish as it is to imagine
that you can treat complex psychological
disorders with chemicals it is insane to
attempt this with children yes in all
but the most extreme cases because what
you are doing simultaneously even if you
manage to do something that temporarily
Alters a pattern in some desirable way
you are disrupting the self-corrective
process that might leave this person
intact as an adult all right Josh this
is fascinating as I hoped it would be I
have learned a lot already my model is
getting better based on what you're
describing uh I also think I see based
on what you said here uh in the last few
minutes uh the connection between these
patterns that have long been somewhat
understood at least in individuals and
families and the dysfunction that we see
across civilization for lack of a better
term the the woke Revolution obviously
has some of these characteristics so do
you want to flesh out what you see the
connection between uh these these
psychological cluster be patterns and
and dysfunction of society yeah thank
yeah I think woke is cluster B I think
woke is cluster B I think another term I
think there are a number of terms that
we use in different contexts that all
point to the same fundamental reference
okay so let's let's just call it the
referent I'm not even going to say that
cluster B is the base cluster B is one
term to describe the referent the actual
phenomenon itself or the set of
phenomena sometimes we call it cluster b
sometimes we call it woke sometimes we
call it cult Dynamics sometimes we call
it political
authoritarianism um number of different
ways I believe all of those things are
pointing to the same underlying
psychological mechanisms the same states
of mind the same broken states of mind I
think this
because um I used I used to be somebody
that you would have called
woke I um and I I what I'm about to say
I offered descriptively it is not
judgmental toward anyone else it's
simply to let people know where I'm
coming from and why I say what I
say I was a leftist a a card carrying
Democrat all of my adult life I was a
progressive leftist I wasn't just a
center-left person I was on the woke
side um I got my
start
in well things were different in those
days but when I was 16 years old I was
already becoming a local celebrity in my
town I was the poster boy for a new
ordinance a gay rights ordinance in
Syracuse New
York uh that would have it did
successfully pass it made it illegal
within the city of Syracuse to fire an
employee simply on the ground of
homosexuality I had run into that
problem at my grocery store employer
and um I I had come out unusually early
in those days I was about 13 when I came
out publicly in in the mid to late 80s
which was not very common in those days
um and I was I be I was I don't want to
over eg it but I was used um by
political activists who saw an
articulate young
man uh who was not afraid to talk to the
camera I made a great poster boy for
this this campaign right so I've been
doing leftist politicking for a very
long time I I no longer consider myself
a leftist I did not go and join the
Republican party I'm not a card carrying
member of any party um most people on
the left would describe me today as a
conservative
um uh but the these these these words
and definitions are are often they're
tools and weapons against people rather
than they are enlightening descriptors
so um people will describe me however
they want but I'm certainly not a
leftist I'm not a
liberal
um and that changed for me only seven
years ago this is recent I'm 49 today
this started happening when I was about
41 years
old um and I I'll do this briefly and
I'll also preface this by saying to
anyone listening I am doing this
descriptively because I want you to
understand my thought process this is
not fishing for sympathy I do not ask
for nor do I want people to think of me
as somebody they need to say I'm so
sorry um you know oh what a horrible
life you had I'm not looking for
sympathy I'm not fishing for any
emotional support from anyone this is
simply
descriptive my mother as I alluded to
before my mother is deranged she's not
just a not great mother she is deranged
and for those she has what I call a
combination of borderline and
narcissistic personality disorders I
also I believe she also has context
dependent sociopathic
traits I did not recognize this until I
was about 41 years
old
um our childhood growing up was a
mixture
of I'll put it to you this way those of
you of a certain age probably 40 or
older I'm getting older now and so my
cultural references don't hit younger
Generations anymore I can't help that
I'm sorry I don't know your world and
you don't know mine um but if you want
to know the kind of person that my
mother was that her children experienced
I'll give you two movie characters and
ask you to make a composite out of them
Joan Crawford and Mommy Dearest and
Margaret White the mother in the horror
film Carrie the religious fanatic mother
if the people who have seen these movies
and understand those cultural references
is my mother was a combination of these
two
people um if that sounds extreme and if
people are are are want to react by
saying oh but those movies were so
ridiculous I can tell you from my point
of view I didn't see anything in either
of those movies that struck me as
unbelievable or extreme I saw things in
those movies that looked like the
interior of our home okay those mothers
exist they're not one in one million
either thank God they're not they're not
one in five but they sure as hell are
not one in a million and they're not
even one in a hundred there's a lot more
of them than that so let me just say I
believe such mothers would have been
vanishingly rare in the ancestral past
that okay in a harsh environment in
which food is limited and the ability to
partner with people was the difference
between uh persisting through tough
times and
starving there would have been a strong
selective
Force against pathology that
severe um you know a self-terminating
strategy I would say yeah that that yeah
what we have is a society that has
produced such
excess that it allows patterns that
would otherwise have self-terminated to
persist and so what we see is those
patterns spreading especially since um
they are transmissible absolutely
absolutely
so what what that meant was that my
childhood was filled with it half of our
childhood my brother and sister and
I um was my mother and my violent uh
stepfather so there was also an abusive
personality disordered father figure in
the house
um uh but the majority of our childhood
he was not part of that picture that was
a 5 to six year period and then was put
out of the house so that was early
rather than late yeah for me it was
between the ages of five and um no four
years old and uh nine to 10 years old
that that my stepfather was part of our
lives so short in duration or
comparatively short in duration but in a
phase when it was liable to have the
biggest developmental effect yeah I mean
as an example you know we three children
watched him try to murder my mother so
that is the kind of childhood that I had
and yes it's extreme I know it's extreme
but it is not as rare as your audience
thinks it is it it really isn't I'm I'm
glad that it's not common but these
things don't just take place on what we
used to call movie of the week right um
that's the childhood that I grew up in
that distorted me severely
psychologically
um I I am a typical outcome of that
childhood there's nothing unusual about
the person that I became I have
struggled with major clinical depression
I've been diagnosed with
panic disorder um major clinical
depression obsessive compulsive disorder
uh Tourette's like tick symptoms um I
spent 22 years as a severe alcoholic and
self-destructive I'm not I'm not an
alcoholic anymore the I am common I am a
typical run-of-the-mill outcome of that
kind of
childhood I didn't know what was wrong
with my family until I was 41 years old
and after an extended period of not
living physic close to my mother and
that part of the family I brought her
back into my life I bought a house for
her to live in as she retired and got
older it was a very I made a series of
very bad mistakes and within two
years everything that all of the
insanity of my childhood was now back in
my face in my 40s and in bright Living
Color and I had told myself a fairy
story that if I could solve my mother's
chronic poverty and my and my mother's
chronic um need to feel safe and
protected if I could do that if I could
give her this affordable place to live
and solve that problem then she'd become
the calm and nurturing person that she
really was
underneath
no so so so just to fill that in for uh
people for whom this is a new topic
you're laughing now because that is a uh
implausible thought psychologically
speaking given the nature of these
disorders yes correct um the they don't
get better most for the most part um it
was such a crisis at 41 that I I had
what we colloquial call colloquially
call a nervous
breakdown it was a it was a turning
point in my life and I had to make a
decision and the decision I made uh was
to sue my mother and evict her from my
house and to put her out of my life
entirely it was the very hardest most
painful and brutal year of my life but
it was also the best thing that ever
happened to me it set me free for the
first time in my life so I that's when I
learned what cluster be was I I finally
had a taxonomy and a system that could
explain to me what I had always thought
of as my mother's peculiar Insanity that
I can never explain to anyone else I
realized that there there actually was
an explanation for it but very quickly
after coming to that realization and
deciding that I would longer have that
as part of my domestic life I looked
around and I
said good God almighty this is happening
in the world around me and not only is
it happening in the world around me it's
my friends it's my political tribe it's
the people that I've been hanging around
with I have surrounded myself with
people who are acting out a version of
my childhood it rocked me Brett to my
core it it destabilized everything I
thought was true about the world
over seven
years that led me to my current view
that cluster be style emotion cluster be
style psychology and victim games that I
knew well from home have become
normalized and are woke this is woke the
screaming people out on the street you
we remember this from 2016 during the
Donald Trump election now I did say I
remind everyone I already did stipulate
that I believe that Donald Trump is
himself a clinical narcissist so uh you
know even if you are some of you in the
audience are emotionally reacting to me
right now because you may not like that
I'm saying some very not nice things
about lots of left stuff I also
recognize the problem on the other side
too but the reaction we had to that the
reaction I had to it Brett here I'll I
I'll tell you I'll tell you what I did
election night
2016 I stayed up all night
crying crying that Donald Trump was
elected crying that this horrible man
was going to um yes it's embarrassing of
course it's histrionic it was an
absolutely emotionally histrionic
reaction and it was not an intellectual
reaction I was still stuck this was just
the beginning of my coming out of of who
I was as a person back then but you saw
this you saw people on the street
literally screaming at the top of their
lungs in genuine emotional distress
toddler level emotional distress that's
extreme but that's an example um
histrionic or borderline personality
style Behavior inability to regulate
emotions um exaggerated emotions and
then I I began to see that all of these
people that you know I went to Sarah
Lawrence College um I was a card
carrying liberal decolonized this you
know white people are terrible men are
all misogynist this was me right I
regurgitated this bile most of my life
um it's clear to me now that this is a
case of reversal it's a case of
narcissistic reversal if you want to
point to the to the one trait the one
characteristic that almost always
indicates at least cluster be style
thinking even if we're not to say that
this person has a disorder
reversing the truth is the key black is
white bitter is sweet good is bad ugly
is beautiful that's woke woke has
reversed everything so we have
organizations like BLM that claim to be
full of victims of racism who are
actually abusive and and very obviously
some of them Psychopathic they're
burning buildings down right endangering
the lives of people burning down
unabashedly racist unabashed racist but
they project it onto other people they
say you are doing this to me you the
white man are doing this to me you the
white woman are doing this to me um
trans is the same thing it is now abuse
we are actually normal people normal
people who show up on shows like Good
Morning America and ABC Nightly News and
and the New York Times and
MSNBC allegedly normal people say as if
it were normal that the people who are
trying to stop boy children from having
their testicles taken off and trying to
stop girl children from having their
breast sliced off the people trying to
stop that are the abusers who are
killing those children it is it is if I
were a religious person I say this on
the show it is satanic it is satanic in
its reversal it is the LIE it is the
original lie and it is wicked and evil
we are living in a Land of complete
moral moral and conceptual inversion
that I believe is what characterizes our
woke
era yeah there is something powerfully
upside down about it it's not just
nonsense it's the inverse of the truth
and it
is ironically
imperiling the system that has offered
the best hope of any system in history
of actually leveling the playing field
yes it is it is it is destroying the
Cure in a
false
and uh
implausible quest to cure the disease
with the
poison yes and it's
it's it's bad it's it's much worse I
think some I think I think more people
are starting to see how bad it is but
even just a couple of years ago I I
you know I can I'm sure that you can I'm
sure that there's a if you will an
empathic way that you can connect to
this I'm betting that you you have
experienced some of this in your own
sphere
um so I sometimes I still I I it's like
for a moment I forget that the world is
what it is and I I forget and I think
that it's it's the normal world that I
used to think existed and I'm shocked
awake and I say oh my this is really
happening this is actually happen
happening we're actually calling this
the mangala level mutilation of children
we're actually calling that love we're
calling it care this is real Josh you're
not having a nightmare you're actually
awake you're living a nightmare yes it's
it it is literally a nightmare and I I
say this without without conscious
hyperbole I don't mean to exaggerate
this I mean this very plainly we are
living in a dystopian science fiction
film it's not coming it's already here
yes it's here and it has captivated
institutions with a great deal of power
which is terrifying now I do believe
that something tactical on what I call
the blue
team has come to understand that as much
as it wished to suppress discussion of
this pathology it has failed for the
same reason that it failed to enforce
its
Orthodoxy um through the main media
because we found places to discuss this
that were not under its control and as
much as it tried to stamp them out it
failed in this case still trying oh
still trying and with respect to the
woke nonsense it is also still trying
but the fact is people reasonable people
people with common sense people who are
able to extrapolate properly have been
discussing this pathology have stared
down the stigmas that are used to
silence them and many people are now
awake at least
partially to the
paradoxes and the absurdity of for
example mutilating children in the Name
of Love yep um so that has caused I
believe a tactical shift on the blue
team which is staring at a election
picture that threatens to upend their
control and they are creating
distance with um
wokeism I believe it's purely cynical
and strategic okay um and in fact one
thing that I have faced which viewers of
Darkhorse uh will
recognize is that the those on the blue
team who are attempting to distance
themselves from woke for electoral
reasons have a problem problem which is
that there are people like Heather and
me who have been trying to call
attention to this horror who are on the
left yep and they do not wish to empower
us oh no right they do not wish to right
they they
absolutely uh see it as an existential
threat if they have to admit that we
were right then they will have to listen
to us on other topics like the horror of
the vaccination campaign that they have
just deployed so they have now um
arranged a narrative in which Once Upon
a Time um I was a decent chap teaching
at a college who did correctly spot the
problem of woke and then went insane
right that's the narrative um so anyway
I don't mean to descend down that rabbit
hole but I just want to point out do
expect woke to um be deemphasized IED by
those who have been pushing it and
expect them to bend backward really
believed that you know we know you know
there were some of us who really went
extreme and we probably should have we
probably should have spoken up a little
bit more about that but that was never
the the heart of our program and you
know as as you know with all due respect
to people like Heather hying and and and
Brett um you know while they had a point
in the beginning they didn't stay on the
side of sanity and what we need right
now what we all need right now is just
to really calmly just understand that
there's truth on both Sid yeah I know I
can write the whole goddamn thing yep
yeah it's happening every single day I
mean look you know you of course
everybody knows I know this I mean I I
didn't know who you were the first time
I heard your name and saw your face was
was um in documentaries about the
Evergreen Fiasco that threw you and
Heather
out um obviously I stayed and paid
attention um but in a in a much less
dramatic and smaller
venue I lost my career of 20 years it's
it's coming up on a year that um I was
forced out of my job as the 20-year
director of a nonprofit Consumer
Protection Organization by a coup within
the organization a leftist coup within
the organization to smear my name to
extort donors and say um they lined up
Don uh our major donors pulled out if
you don't fire Joshua slokum and make a
public statement disavowing him for what
he does in his private time and his
political views we're going to bankrupt
the organization and pull out our
membership all that dirty [__] was
pulled and um
as as I'm sorry most of these nonprofits
are in fact leftist even when they call
themselves
nonpartisan as leftist organizations do
they left they left me to hang out to
dry so yes I did actually resign rather
than being fired but had I not resigned
I would have been fired three days later
and I would have had no leverage at all
so let's let's fill if assuming you're
willing let's fill that in a little bit
so people understand what you had
dedicated your life to that you were
tossed out for uh political
incorrectness yeah yeah can you describe
your your uh your work yes I spent 20
years as the executive director of a
nonprofit organization called funeral
consumers Alliance yes I realized that
sounds strange I ask people think of it
like it was the Consumer Reports
Magazine but only for the funeral
purchase the goal of the organization
was to educate the public because the
the funeral industry funerals and
Cemetery sales are more than 20 billion
dollar a year in this country we spend a
great deal of money burying our debt
thousands of people every year feel that
they have been overcharged that it's
burdensome expensive and that they have
to make very consequential financial
decisions on the worst day of of their
lives without sufficient information and
time to make those decisions so fca's
goal was to give people factual
information about their legal rights
factual information so they could
evaluate the economic value of what they
were asking for so they could shop
around and we also lobbied on behalf of
consumers for regulations that would
better protect the public from predatory
sales practices so you were working to
protect the public from an industry that
takes advantage of people's grief that
financially takes advantage of people's
grief and even in that context you were
effectively thrown out because of
political differences that had nothing
to do with this correct I I started with
Kevin Kevin uh the other half of
disaffected this show was his idea this
this this is his baby uh he talked me
into it um we started the show we've
been talking about this hypothesis from
day one the very first episode in late
January of 2021 we said it explicitly
we're living in a cluster B
world I knew when I started that I did
know that the likely outcome was going
to be that I was going to be pushed out
of my job this was too important I
wasn't willing to keep my mouth
shut um it took about a year and a half
but it happened and why did it happen
what happened the same story that you've
been through Brett the same story that
anybody else working for a an any
organization that doesn't explicitly
disavow wo
um non this nonprofit had a lot of very
good people a lot of very charitable
kind-hearted volunteers but it was
extraordinarily heavily weighted toward
hard
leftism and then it began to be taken
over by the set most known for woke the
HR women the millennial white women yes
women um who get their jollies and their
kicks by canceling other people smearing
their reputations and looking like lady
Bountiful most gracious mama in the
world who cares about all her little
children of all Races and all the
genders and this that and the other
thing these people whether they're men
or women these are not kind people
they're not good people they are
narcissists they are exploitative some
of them not all some of them are
sadistic as hell and they like hurting
other people they like taking their jobs
away from them that is what happened to
me so let me just point out the the
larger pattern here because yes I I have
lived it in a very different form y the
tragedy of what happened at Evergreen
was that Evergreen was exactly the right
place if you were a student who was not
a good fit for a normal College
environment but had high potential yeah
there are a huge number of those people
who need a place like Evergreen and what
the woke active IST did by creating a
riot around a phony claim of racism
largely against me was destroy the place
so that it now does not exist in any
meaningful sense it still hobbles along
with huge State subsidies but the fact
is it is not capable of doing the job of
educating that it once was and so the
point is in a
symbolic um
hemorrhage ostens ibly about protecting
oppressed people it hurt people who were
actually benefiting from something in
your case your organization was
protecting consumers from a predatory
industry those consumers were hurt by a
internal woke
takeover that had nothing to do with
funeral services or the funeral industry
right it was petty and
harmful to the exact people the
organization was designed to help and I
know other cases let me tell let me tell
you how harmful sure
right there's there's no staff in the
organization anymore the office is
closed when I left within four or five
months of my leaving they eliminated the
second staff position they closed down
the office now there are some volunteers
who are still trying to keep it going
but they allowed they allowed and if any
of them are watching I am talking to you
and about you
you allowed Wicked people who did not
have your constituency's best interests
at heart to push you into pushing me out
at the expense of the organization and
now it's it exists on paper only you
know this isn't I'm not even bitter
about this anymore I'm glad I'm out of
that that now but yes they left
Evergreen and tatters my organization
was left practically non-existent this
happens to group after Group after group
College after college after college it
never works out to anyone's benefit
except the people at the at the heart of
these campaigns except the petty
tyrants um and I will just say we also
uh have a close friend who um literally
had an organization that he founded uh
brought to its knees over
his his uh willingness to acknowledge
his friendship to fail to
disavow Heather who is oh I'm sure
deemed to be a transphobe which she is
not um so anyway the point is this was
an environmental organization and a good
one most of them are not this was a good
one that was actually doing real good in
the world and the point is what was the
consequence of this woke
campaign it was a setback for the
environment your example is a setback
for consumers who are going to face this
predatory industry without anyone
looking out for their interests my
situation was a setback for the students
who were benefiting from an educational
environment that could actually pay
attention to their individual needs yes
let me this this is an excellent place
to insert this I think to tie some
Concepts together for people this is a
perfect example of our my thesis and
Kevin's thesis that as in the home so in
society this does scale from domestic
abuse to public life so a domestically
abusive family a family with a
borderline or a narcissist parent at the
core that is a cluster B family even
though the children don't have
personality disorders every single
member of that family is playing a role
in a cluster B scripted drama play one
of the roles one of the most common
roles that children play and other
family members play uh that you call it
you become what they call a flying
monkey for the narcissist and it's a
reference to the uh to The Wizard of Oz
the witch didn't do her own dirty work
she had an army of monkeys with wings
that she sent out to poison Dorothy and
the Scarecrow and all this other stuff
so you become a flying monkey for the
narcissist for the pathological person
you believe that they are actually the
victim they claim to be you believe
their stories that the people around
them are hurting them and that you out
of loyalty feel that you need to go
defend mom or dad um and how it works in
the family I was a flying monkey for my
mother for decades my mother had be
convinced that my sister was clinically
insane it was actually my mother not my
sister I abused my sister at my mother's
behest I didn't think I was abusing her
I didn't think I was mistreating her but
I didn't believe her I called her a liar
um it's sick it's grotesque you know I
mean I there's some things that I've
done and that anyone in a family like
this has done that are very shameful but
this is what happens this is happening
too the friend the person at the
environmental organization who would not
disavow friendship with Heather was
being a flying monkey for a narcissist
or a pathological person to ex in
exactly a parallel way to the way
children are conscripted to abuse their
siblings this is how it scales well he
refused to be a flying monkey okay which
cost him his
organization you're gonna be punished
one way or another yeah yeah um that
which is a you know that is a a
insightful and terrifying portrait that
you paint right it also means that one
has to be careful to uh understand that
the source of the abuse that they are on
the wrong end of may or may not be the
person delivering it correct right that
person may be under a
misapprehension
yep all right so um couple things I
wanted to just introduce in the
discussion before you uh continue
painting the picture of what's happened
to society
one the the woke
Revolution does an excellent job of
triggering a circuit that turns
off I use empathy and sympathy
differently than most people um in
common parlament it turns off
empathy for people who deserve it the
students who showed up at my classroom
and called me a racist had never met me
and under ordinary
circumstances I if I had met them in any
context other than that one I would have
won most of them if not all of them over
because I was somebody who thinks deeply
about the issues that they think they
care about and has something to say that
is actually
useful but what they did was they cause
these people to see me as a monster
before they ever showed up it made it
essentially
impossible to alert them to the fact
that they were doing something that
their their conscience would not accept
if it understood it and so that you can
see also
in the
um I'm not sure exactly what the
explanation for what happened in Israel
two days ago was but I take the
celebrations that have erupted around
the world of this
attack to be a terrifying indication of
what it looks like for a
population to truly
lose um their own humanity and their
sense of others Humanity the brutality
of the attack never mind whether or not
you think an attack was justified the
brutality of the attack that unfolded
the murdering of parents in front of
their children and worse is nothing a
reasonable person could celebrate no and
yet there was public celebration
cheering dancing in the streets right
but my point is that what you are seeing
when you watch people celebrate
this is people
who
somehow do not regard the suffering of
other
people as meaningful or even real and I
I don't know I'm sure we all carry genes
that would allow that circuitry to exist
in us because the history of history is
exactly the sort of place where that
characteristic existed in large measure
but I do not
believe
that I could Delight in the torture of
my worst enemy even at my lowest moment
there's no point at which I fail to
understand that that is a human
being even if I thought they needed to
suffer it's not the kind of thing I
would find myself celebrating so in any
case the fact that the woke
revolutionaries have participated in
these
celebrations and have cheered them on on
social media the fact that they have
made excuses for those celebrating
atrocities
really should make people think about
what it is they are partnering with we
do not want a world in which anybody
celebrates
atrocities if they happen they are
shameful for all of us
and I guess I think a lot of people and
in fact I've heard and I've had
arguments with lots of people
who make excuses and they tell us that
the claims and the
uh the proposals that are being Advanced
by the woke revolutionaries are not what
they seem that uh it's hyperbolic
language but that's not true these are
people who are experimenting they are
toying with the very circuitry that
precedes genocide yes sir and I I don't
maybe maybe this chapter will cause
people to think twice having now seen
it but obviously the mutilation of
children um atrocities against civilians
these are all things that nobody should
find acceptable and yet there is a
sizable fraction of the population that
apparently
does yeah and and and at what I'm not
Brad I'm not an optimist
um people who call themselves optimist
call me a a cynical or um and of course
as someone you know everybody who's
called cynical says the same thing that
I'm going to say which is I think I'm
actually a realist who knows at the end
of the day I'm not very hopeful right
now I haven't been hopeful for a
while
um I the the world that I thought
existed does not exist and the human
nature that I believed was real I had a
misunderstanding of human nature a very
profound misunderstanding until recent
years I
think I did
not know that it was
possible I'm I'm still
so I'm still so rocked back on my heels
by the fact that in America in the 21st
century
we can
have I I'm sorry to keep going back to
this but I I think it is I think the
trans the transitioning transgenderism
is is to me the most
fluid deployment of absolute
Insanity um that we could put our
fingers on right now I it is the most
deranged thing I have ever witnessed in
my life at least with respect to
children yeah well um I'll go farther
than I think you're comfortable and I'll
speak only for myself um I I don't think
it's very much better for adults either
I think the entire thing is is is
absolutely deranged I'm not I'm not I'm
not saying that it is or it isn't what
I'm saying no I it is much worse with
children for two reasons yes it is
adults have the right and should have
the right
to
to experiment with whatever it is they
wish to experiment with so long as they
are not doing harm to others and that is
a term we have to Define very carefully
because it is there are lots of ways to
cryptically harm others but I believe
that an adult who truly feels that they
are in the wrong body and within reason
that there are remedies that might
improve their situation and I you know I
think there are examples of adults who
appear to prove that this at least
exists that there are people who are
happier having uh made modifications but
even if that wasn't true so yes even if
that wasn't true I am in no position to
tell an adult uh you don't know what
you're talking about
um yes children the the yes the CH the
children and this is what I was going
for that we live in a society where not
only do
people not react with mobs and
pitchforks to protect children that
someone proposes to do this to not only
do we not do that we affirmatively
celebrate the mutilation on shows like
I'm Jaz
Jennings um we put them on Breakfast
Television we put mothers and it there
are fathers but I'm but this this is
largely a mother's sin and it is my
belief um that the transitioning of
children is simply a modern form of
mowen syndrome by proxy I think it is
exactly not like it it is exactly the
same thing as the classic cases that we
see of parents poisoning children to
make them look as though they're ill to
get attention I don't think it's eerily
like that I think it is exactly the same
thing it's that sick that's me I'm not
saying that you have to agree with me on
no no I I look I can't speak to every
case but uh does that pattern strike me
as a good match it does and the
inversion of reality where those who are
mutilating children are celebrated and
right loving and affirming and those who
are resisting the mutilation of children
are being
portrayed
as putting their lives in Jeopardy right
the the Trope that it is to prevent the
suicides of trans people that we must
rush them to transition when we know
full well that most people who
experience gender dysphoria as children
get over it right their minds correct
correct and uh the other part of it
which which many many people many gay
people have been bringing up we've been
shouting this from the rooftops for
years I think we're finally starting to
be listened to a little bit more um but
the undeniable fact that the numerical
majority of these children are the
children who would grow up to be
homosexuals otherwise you know this it's
just my point in in bringing this up
again is to say that we are living in a
society that is
so morally
deranged that not only are we not
protecting children from this we're
affirmatively praising the very abusive
sick parents and doctors who are doing
it to them and we are threatening and
successfully taking away custody
livelihood and moral social
respectability and reputation from the
parents trying to save the children from
this we are so far in reversal that it
this is I'm having one of those
instances right now where I can barely
believe it so if we live in that society
and we do live in that
Society what hope do we have that
anybody is going to look at what Hamas
just did and actually react like any
moral person might have reacted what can
we depend on can we count on on our
compatriots for
anything yeah I you know uh I was raised
in a house
where the Holocaust was
a regular topic of
discussion and it was not overwrought
discussion it was discussion it was
analytical discussion designed I think
to make
sure that we got the message about how
this happened that it could happen here
and that there were things that we could
know about it that would allow us to
know that it was happening and I as an
adult I did not live I did not expect to
live to see this kind of
transition at
home I could imagine it would have
happened elsewhere I could imagine it
would have happened here but
a long time in the future to see this
transition in real time where people's
empathy is broken intentionally
systematically it's not hard at all to
imagine people uh who once viewed you as
a regular person like they are um
ushering you towards whatever cattle
cars and gas Chambers uh would look like
in the new in the new era it is very
easy to understand how that happens once
you've seen a transition like this where
you know we have done absolutely ghastly
things to Children uh and and to and to
people under I mean that you talked
earlier Brett about the the uh the
vaccination uh
campaign I I think most of us I think
this is probably true for you and
Heather um I think you probably lost a
lot of friends and colleagues um during
the Evergreen thing um most people do I
lost again you know my my story is no
more dramatic and is less dramatic than
what some other people have gone through
but I lost almost my entire Friendship
Circle uh even people who had known me
for 30 years over the last seven years
and I not only lost some of them but
some of them and and it it was painful
to do it's still painful to me some of
them I actively threw out of my life and
said get away from me I never want to
speak to you again
I don't trust you I don't respect you
I'm scared to turn my back on you I
never thought I'd say that to you but
you are not the person I thought you
were I have actively pushed people out
as well because I feared people that I
used to say were my friends and I mean
that it's not egging it to say that
right I've seen people that I thought I
knew their soul I thought I knew their
moral core and I saw them buckle down to
coid in ways that said to me
Josh I are you sure that this person
who's been your friend for this many
years would not call the public health
Authorities on you and when I couldn't
answer yes that was it that's how bad it
is so I've now been through several of
these events in my own life and I've
noticed a
pattern which is that in every
case
these divisive
crises reveal people's character and and
each time I've seen the same pattern
there are people you thought you could
trust who absolutely disappoint you
and then there are people that you never
expected maybe you didn't even know them
ahead of time who rise to the challenge
and they shine and you see that somebody
maybe you didn't know their name but
they turn out to have tremendous
strength of character and insight and
they stand up at the right moment and
defend you for no reason right no reason
other than that it's the right thing to
do and so each time I have lost friends
and it's
painful and I have gained
people who are much higher quality and I
call this the painful upgrade right it
keeps upgrading your Social
Circle
and I now have to look back on the
world before I had been through any of
these
and realize that I was walking
around
with with
trust in
people that carried with them the
ability to absolutely betray under the
worst possible circumstances and that
that's dangerous you are far better to
know who actually has the strength of
character to face these things and to
limit your significant interactions to
that pool of people right it is a gift
in fact to know who cannot be
trusted uh with your
well-being and I you know I don't like
to say that but I think people need to
be alerted to this because you know
people are not labeled they don't even
know themselves whether they're capable
of this until they're faced with the
situation it's the crisis that reveals
it and um uh you know it's the silver
lining of these terrible chapters is
that it does tell you who's really on
your
team you know what scares me Brett the
most the the thing that keeps me up at
night
existentially
is and and I don't know how far to go
with this I think there's a lot to it
but I'm not entirely certain and I
cannot accurately separate my own
emotional projection from whether I'm
analyzing this as rigorously as I should
so with those provisos
we talk we talk about drug addicts and
alcoholics and one of the common ways
that we talk about them and understand
them um if they're able to get sober and
kick their addiction is we say that
person has to hit rock bottom it has to
become so unbearable and so painful that
he that he rescues himself and I think
there's a great of Truth to that I think
that is usually the case there may be
other ways of doing it but I don't think
they're common
ways I know
personally that to to become free
from and I'm I'm not free of the
psychological damage that my childhood
did to me I'm trying to make something
better out of that experience at this
point in my life but and again this is
I'm not fishing for pity I'm doing this
for illustration purposes because I want
people to understand this on a human
level you
know I will never be the person I could
have been in some ways because my psyche
was damaged during my formative years by
incredible abuse the same is true of my
sister my brother and millions of other
people have been through that that
that's
true but so there are lifelong
consequences to
this in order for me
but but I'm in a much better place today
than I was seven years ago when I was
blind to this and I was still under the
sway of of of the deranged
household but to get there I had to be
completely psychologically broken and I
was I mean I I was very close I was as
close as I've ever been as an adult to
to actively considering suicide right
I'm not I'm not a suicidal person you
know I'm a depressive um I'm a neurotic
heavily neurotic but I'm not a suicidal
person I was during that
time
and the the depth of pain and fear
absolute Soul shaking fear that I lived
in at that time I hope I never have to
feel
again but it was necessary if it had
been less painful than it was I don't
think I would have broken free and I
don't think I would have had the
opportunity to re-evaluate the entire
way that I saw the world so if this is
the case for the individual for most of
us as individuals that we have to really
hit the wall before we make a
significant change if that scales up to
society that's what scares me
Brett how far do how low do we have to
go as Americans as westerners how bad
does it have to get how many people need
to die how many of us need to lose our
minds before we hit rock
bottom well that is a terrifying thought
never never considered it that way um I
do think that there is something very
real about the phenomenon you're
describing and that you know we have a a
metaphor in in evolutionary biology
called the Adaptive landscape and it's
useful in various ways here it's kind of
a loose analogy but in order to get from
a low Peak where you were living to a
higher Peak you have to go through a
valley and these valleys are very dark
and perilous places there's no guarantee
that you do get out the other side so
hitting rock bottom is something not
everybody survives yep but it may be
necessary to do it if you hope to live
in a different state and I would I would
introduce one concept
here I
think I just think this is one of the
missing pieces of the puzzle when we
talk about um victims
and uh abuse and
um psychological trauma all of these
things there is a a rather exact
psychological analogy to be
drawn in the Damage Done by um
abuse to the Damage Done by physical
injury you know there's a reason that we
say you know that you were hurt there's
a reason that word Works in both the
physical and the psychological realm and
it's because there's a tight parallel
between these things and what I would
point
out is that when you have been damaged
by someone or some
event that damage
is a
persistent
vulnerability it makes it impossible to
live well and that the right thing to do
is to aim for the same thing that
happens to a physical injury it starts
out as a
wound and the right thing to do is to
aim to scar
over now a scar is not as good as the
tissue that was damaged it's a
patch as you say you will never be the
person that you would have been if you
hadn't faced the abuse you faced right
but you scar over so that you can
function and you know you keep saying
that you don't say this or that to gain
anybody's pity you don't strike me as a
pitiable person maybe you were but you
strike me as somebody who has figured
out how to take the damage that you
sustained and to uh to scar it over and
to function and to do so you know not
just you know treading water but you're
doing good in the world you're uh you're
bringing light to this issue you work
working to protect people from a
predatory industry this is all uh very
positive stuff so um in any case the I
think one of the things that I see in
the woke
revolutionaries and uh all of the
correlated
pathologies is that there is no desire
to scar over and where we once would
have heralded somebody for facing
something terrible and then making
something of themselves what there is is
a desire to keep the wound open and it's
part of a pattern of learned
helplessness yes yes where
people the whole idea
is I am
owed a living for what I've been through
or something along those lines and it's
a con right it's it's it's a
parasitic way of viewing the world and
and it I think one of the things for
people of a certain
age it's this wallowing
in
self-pity that is so destructive right
we we we used to look with honor at
people who faced something and stood up
to it and now it's like that's the
problem right it's all about you were
injured you'll forever be injured and
that's somebody else's problem and will
permanently be rather than you know hey
look play the cards that you've been
dealt scar
over yeah and and you're exact you're
exactly right
um there there is an entire generation
now at least one generation For Whom the
majority of them do not understand that
there's another way to be a human
being they they literally do not know I
I've I've I talk about this on the show
sometimes uh
we I perceive that there is a
profound and
historically unparalleled cultural drop
off a cliff that happens after my
generation onto the Next Generation so
from Gen X which is me to Millennials
and and then to Zoomers or gen I hate I
can't believe I just said that word it's
so annoying
um baby boomer silent
generation my parents my
grandparents yes in the 20th century
which is all that well nobody remembers
that anymore either um but we say oh
every generation that comes along says
oh I don't want to be like my parents
and and and and the the parents always
look at the children and say they're
messing everything up and things used to
be better in the old days and there's
some truth to that I do not believe
that's what's going on here I think that
after Generation X there is a rip and
actual rip in our skin that separates me
from there we no longer have a shared
culture so my grandmother's generation
and my mother's generation even though
we were different Generations we shared
20th century culture I knew the the hit
records of their teen years right they
we we had only three channels of
Television so everybody was watching
Walter
kronite
um you get to Millennials and gen Z
Brett people you know I I've had people
tell me they think I'm exaggerating and
I really don't think I am it is almost
as if some of these young people do not
actually believe the world did exist at
all before they were born and it's not
just that they look at old movies or
pictures of old houses with old
technology with sort of amusement which
we all
do I detect contempt and
fear it's as if there's something
disgusting about about the way the world
used to be something threatening that
they don't want to get close to it's I
can't quite put my finger on it but
there's something very different about
this and I think it it is it's part of
our social fabric
unraveling well um let me I have I have
seen this close up in a couple of
different ways and I have some thoughts
on it that uh are not a complete picture
but I I look forward to hearing what
you'll make of
them one
your point about Walter kronite I make
the same point and I use the same
example uh and so I know what comes back
right like you think Walter kronite was
telling you the truth you actually
believe that's not the point right
that's not the point the the and in fact
I make this point in another way if you
had to choose between a culture in which
people read really good books but not
the same ones versus a culture in which
everybody read the same stuff but it was
of lower quality you might be better off
in a culture where people shared the
content of these things and I feel the
same way about the Walter kronite
phenomenon which is if you all start
with the
same
assumptions then you at least have a way
to talk to each other and I'm not
arguing that bad assumptions aren't
poison they are sure but the point is we
can't even talk about which of our
assumptions are bad because we don't
start from any anything we can agree on
like literally at this point we can't
agree that pedophilia is bad we don't
agree that 2 plus 2 necessarily equals
for we don't agree that men men can't
become women right we literally can't
agree on anything and when I was
teaching at Evergreen Heather and I used
to make a point of taking our students
out into the field and we had great
students they were all Millennials at
that point
um we would take them into the field now
they weren't all Millennials they were
some older students but but mostly the
rooms were filled with
Millennials and we would go into the
field just for the purpose of breaking
ourselves away from social
media uh coming to understand each other
you know where everybody's letting their
hair down we would sit around the
campfire right there was often a
biological point to these things but
really mostly they were Retreats so we
could learn how to interact with each
other and we would ask for people
to uh bring songs to the campfire things
that we could sing together just to be
human it was almost impossible to find
any song that even all of the students
knew in common right they were all
listening to their own stuff they had so
much choice and you know I think in some
ways the amount of really good music
that's available now actually exceeds
what I had access to at their age you
know the the nature of the internet has
allowed uh smaller artists to find an
audience people who have really
important stuff to say but the lack of a
shared
culture
means they just don't even know how to
interact yes and I will put one more one
more piece on that puzzle I was talking
to uh Zach my older son he's
19 about what had taking place in Israel
and he said you know I think there's
something you ought to
know I said 'what's that and he said I
have literally this is him talking I
have literally not seen a single post
from anybody in my generation on what
happened and we talked about this for a
little bit why would that
be and the answer is I
think this
event defies the normal Rules by which
this generation would decide which the
right side of History
was the woke side is
blindly Pro Palestinian such that they
are willing to excuse Hamas terrorism
brutality
atrocities and there are of
course uh lots of Jews people who have
family in Israel people who um
understand the
geopolitical uh danger of
destabilization in this region
and so the point is this generation has
gotten used to having a I think it's
phony but a North star that tells them
what they're supposed to believe and
they level their arguments based on what
they have been handed as a position they
don't question it and in a point where
we don't know how this is going to
break they are uh they are at loose ends
and so they they don't talk about it
because the last thing you want to do is
Venture a position that turns out to be
on what will ultimately be declared to
be the wrong side of History yeah right
that's like that's a terrifying thought
to them and so anyway I I agree there is
something there is something wrong with
the way culture
functions for genes and I think pretty
clearly for Millennials that is putting
us in Jeopardy because it
is it is Reviving The mechanisms that
allow for things like genocide we are
toying with those very
tropes we may find out very
soon yeah I I wish people understood
that that's really where we were because
you know I I I find myself again and
again trying to wake people to the fact
that the West is in tremendous Jeopardy
yes and that in fact it is no mystery
what happens if the West comes apart
it's already in terrible condition if it
comes apart what happens is the prior
version of human interaction history
will reassert itself and we will be back
in a NeverEnding series of wars and
genocides as lineages attempt to drive
each other from the Earth
it's not somewhere that any reasonable
person could want us to go and the
frivolousness with which we are dealing
with that risk is truly
frightening it is and it's the sort of
thing that
I you have to be conscious of it you
have to know I want people to to be
conscious of it as well I want them to
see it for what it really is and and
yet if you are fully conscious of it or
maybe I should just say Me Maybe This
isn't reflective of other people but if
I'm fully conscious of this every minute
of every hour of the day I can't take it
I'm conscious of it most of the time but
it's it is wearing it is this is not a
state for any of us this is not a normal
psychological State this is not a
sustainable
state yeah it's not a sustainable State
and I fear that some combination
of the constant state of disruption that
these younger Generations have existed
in and the clumsy remedies that have
been offered them in pharmaceutical form
the massive number of distractions that
they have been presented which allow
them to live an entire life without
knowing even even what their own mind
sounds like in a quiet
environment that that is causing them
not to be able to do and actually I
think it goes right to the point you
were making about the way they view the
past they have
to
disavow the recent
past because it is the
proof that it can be better that if you
stop doing this [__] if you stop
emphasizing race if you start tolerating
differences of opinion figuring out how
to Hash them out and not make everything
personal and turn everything into a
cancelable offense if you don't do that
it does not leave you with a perfect
world but it does leave you with a world
that is livable thank you that's exactly
the livable yeah livable and if you knew
if you could teleport these people for
five minutes into that world and just
get a sense
for you know what it is like to live in
a world
where yes there is racism but it's not
decisive it's not present in every
interaction it is an unfortunate feature
of the landscape and it's something that
good people wanted to
reduce right yeah it you know believe me
I have nothing but complaints about the
failure of that earlier world to live up
to its potential but compared to what we
are doing we were at least on the right
track I don't even think we
know I don't even think we know what we
mean anymore collectively as a culture
by most of the things that we claim we
care about I don't think we know what we
mean by racism I don't think we know
what we mean by phobia I don't think we
because none of this stuff I mean
it first the idea that humans are
perfect I think is another poison we
don't have time to get into that but the
idea that it is possible with the human
organism to eliminate racism or
eliminate sexism or eliminate
poverty is a child's
fantasy it is not real it has never been
real in this physical Universe in which
we are embodied it never will be real in
any universe that continues to follow
the laws of physics that have been
bequeathed to us we are not perfect we
are
flawed we are capable
of wonderful and wondrous acts we are
capable of creating art that will make
the most stoic man burst into tears we
are capable of extraordinary compassion
and Grace and we are capable of
depravities worse than anything that you
can dream up and put in a Hollywood
script this is the human
animal most of the
time we we've already seen that it's
possible to have a world not a perfect
world but a world in which that human
animal can live as you said is livable
and can spend a reasonable amount of
that time contented or if not contented
then challenged in an engaging way that
makes you want to get up the next day
that is Being Human that world is
possible but the world that they think
that that the extremely woke think that
the power hungry Psychopaths think or
that the that the naive very younger
Generations think that that we can get
rid of these things that you know well
there'll just be a world someday where
men never say um insulting things about
women and um G you know everybody will
say that they love gay people just as
much as I do and no one will ever look a
scance at a black person that's not we
it's not real and if if we think that to
be happy and to be self-actualized that
we require that world to exist then we
are going to kill ourselves because it
ain't never gonna
exist yeah it's a it's an interesting
point and in fact there is a direct
mirror of what you just said generally
in the issue
of medical
transition
the promise that these people are being
delivered is that the feeling that
something is very desperately wrong is
something that can be cured with this
one
program and the problem is it's a
one-way trip and they have no way of
knowing that in fact much of
their sense of
unease which may in fact be perfectly
accurate it would be perfectly
reasonable for a person to feel a
tremendous constant sense of unease in a
world as broken as the one that we are
currently
creating the idea that they are going to
find a perfect alternative in which all
they've done is flipped a switch and
signed the paperwork and the doctor
switches their gender and they are now
something that feels
good that is not how this works and it
is terrifying to think that they are
only going to discover that after
they've surrendered
their their physiological Health to this
program and yeah so anyway I think I
think the the idea that that is
generally the
error that there is a belief in the
possibility of a world that I swear to
you nobody who had ever built anything
real could believe in right yes if you
if you if you make machines if you you
build
structures I think if you paint a
painting that looks realistic you will
understand that you are going to have to
take this but you're going to have to
give up that to get it and you'll stop
looking for Perfection because it's
impossible which doesn't mean that an
excellent world isn't possible but if
you think Perfection is what we're
shooting for we are not going to achieve
Excellence we're going to achieve
achieve
dystopia are we not
inadvertently
Burning Down The Village to save it are
we not killing the entire world in order
to save it I am afraid that that is
exactly what we are doing and the the
the very troubling thing for me is that
I
believe there are those of us who
understand that and are trying to tell
people it's not that we don't see the
problems you're talking
about but they cannot be solved this way
they cannot be solved this way way they
cannot be solved instantaneously they
cannot be solved completely and your
insistence that that's what we do is
like um it's like you're on a
ship in the middle of the ocean and you
are noticing all the things that are
wrong with that ship and so you decide
to destroy it in the hope that a better
ship will come along it's that crazy
that's not how you do it you can address
the problems of the ship you can talk
about whether or not there's some way to
get a better ship which will also have
problems but destroying the ship on the
faith that the ship is the problem is
going to drown
us
yep well um is there more that we should
say to complete the picture of the uh uh
cluster B cluster bomb cluster [__] that
we face um there's always more but you
know
um I think I don't know that there's
more that we can say right now in here
we covered a lot of covered a lot of
territory big territory yeah yes and I'm
I'm disappointed to say we did not
achieve a perfect world or even a
description of one I mean uh that's
that's a failure but uh I think I think
we've done
well all right Josh uh I want to thank
you for this it's been a very uh
fascinating if not uplifting ation um I
hope that uh Darkhorse listeners will
get as much out of it as I did well
thank you thank you so much um and you
know it it may not be uplifting in the
moment you know this is the world is
grim right now it's Grim but um the fact
that we're having this conversation the
fact that Dark Horse exists that we can
know each other and talk to each other
is one of the things that keeps me going
so it's not a perfect world but it's a
world that has good things in it thank
you yeah I appreciate that and I would
just uh there's a Hy saying that I've
always been fond of we are the ones
we've been waiting for yeah but are we
the ones that we want Brett no we could
probably do better on that front but we
are the ones we've been waiting for
irrespective of that all right it's been
a pleasure uh and to everyone else
thanks for joining
[Music]
us
for